bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission économique inquiète aseptisé
sauf dans ses paroles
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du meilleur ami de la femme des
pierres précieuses bonjour estelle ont
leur ailier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans les séquelles chez koti l'investir
dans les pierres précieuses
c'est la question que de nombreuses
personnes se posent en tondant naïm et
dossiers en temps de crise
et c'est à ces questions que l'on va a
tenté de répondre dans cette émission et
pour cela vous entendrez en deuxième
partie l'éclairage de 6 litres aulas en
négociant en perte est précieuse et
joaillerie mais d'avoir olivier on va
entrer dans le vif du sujet que l'on
vous êtes une bonne idée d'investir dans
les terres chrétiennes
écoutez c'est déjà une bonne idée
d'investir dans autre chose que des
produits financiers qui aujourd'hui sont
en en pleine bulle hystérique même on
pourrait dire puisque vu que les les
élections américaines sont bientôt dans
dans deux mois vous avez une espèce
d'hystérie qui s'est propagé sur toutes
les bourses mondiales sauf peut-être sur
le cac 40 qui est qui est très en retard
mais sûr mais qui a l'habitude d'être en
retard d'ailleurs mais sur toutes les
autres bourses c'est cette poussée par
les banques centrales
c'est une espèce de deux d'hystérie à la
hausse donc aujourd'hui il vaut mieux
être prudent il vaut mieux investir sur
dur elle alors vous pouvez aussi
investir on l'avait vu dans une autre
émission sur de l'or sur de l'argent
métal mai
si vous voulez diversifié bien vous
pouvez acquérir aussi des pierres
précieuses
il est évident que comme sur l'or ou
comme sur l'argent il vaut mieux
s'adresser à des gens qui sont honnêtes
et qui s'y connaissent
parmi les plus convoités le diamant ta
valeur aurait plus que doublé en 20 ans
tour d'horizon halle des fêtes pierre
avec le pire marquage d'emploi novatek
[Musique]
avec la crise économique
tout le monde est à la recherche de
valeurs refuge d'investissements
rentables plutôt que de laisser son
argent en banque et prendre le risque de
le perdre en cas de chute des marchés
alors il dit alors évidemment valeur
refuge parmi toutes qui atteint
d'ailleurs des records depuis la
pandémie s'échangeant à plus de 2000
dollars l'once
et puis et on y pense sans doute un peu
moins les pierres précieuses et autres
j'aime
prenons par exemple le diamant déjà il
faut savoir que lorsqu'on achète un
diamant comme n'importe quel bijou la
tva s'applique sur le caillou et bim
c'est déjà 20% de perdus
d'autre part chaque pierre est unique et
se classe selon de nombreux critères 100
points sa forme sa couleur sa pureté sa
qualité de taille un diamant n'en vaut
pas forcément un autre et lorsqu'on n'y
connaît rien ça peut déboucher sur une
arnaque une revente compliqué et donc un
investissement sacrément risqué
d'ailleurs le marché des diamants peut
parfois aussi plongé pendant la crise
des subprimes selon les échos le prix
des diamants ordinaire inconnue une
chute sensiblement identique à celle des
marchés financiers il faut toutefois
savoir également que le diamant se fait
aussi de plus en plus rares au fil des
années en 20 ans sa valeur aurait plus
que doublé et risquent de continuer à
augmenter fortement durant les années
qui viennent
[Musique]
oui évidemment alors effectivement sacré
henri guaino via le pied aux arcs h
il est d'accord avec la mais c'est comme
tous les investissements c'est à dire
que si vous prenez des baies des
diamants qui sont petit médiocre qualité
évidemment vous avez des risques et vous
avez des risques de fortes baisses en
cas de 2,2 crache sur les marchés
maintenant vous avez aussi des diamants
un petit peu plus exceptionnel on va
dire est qu'ils permettent eux d'avoir
une réserve de valeur et d'avoir
beaucoup moins de volatilité sur le sur
le coup sûr le sur l'or vous savez aussi
en 2008 au moment des subprimes il y
avait une forte baisse de l'or qui a été
reprise après mais il y avait une forte
baisse de l'or parce que ça a servi
aussi à payer les bêtises que certains
avaient fait sur les marchés et qui
avaient des appels de marges et donc
qu'ils sont allés vendre leur or pour
pouvoir répondre aux appels de marge
donc quelle que soit l'institut manquent
eux
vous faites que ce soit l'immobilier que
ce soit lors que ce soit l'argent que ce
soit des pierres vous pouvez avoir ce
phénomène et c'est pour ça qu'il vaut
mieux dans ces cas là à voir le top du
top
parce que vous avez moins de volatilité
sur sûr c'est sur ces pierres ou sur ses
investissements
il faut savoir aussi que on va le voir
là bientôt il n'y a pas que le diamant
vous avez aussi des pierres de couleurs
et que le marché du diamant qui en fait
n'est pas un marché puisqu'il est
contrôlé par la de vire ce donc
maintenant c'est un petit peu comme les
marchés financiers qui sont contrôlés
par les banques centrales et bien là
vous avez un acteur qui forment les prix
et donc en effet vous avez un risque de
ce côté là que vous avez peut-être moins
d'ailleurs mais ça on va le on va le
voir avec philippe que vous avez
peut-être moins avec des pierres de
couleurs merci au lieu d en face à tout
de suite à la deuxième partie cette
notion et on continue à 2 par les
pierres précieuses et pour cela nous
sommes dans liaisons avec philippe
rolland négociant en pierres précieuses
et joaillerie bonjour monsieur roland
renard milan et cash merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bon joueur merci de m'avoir habitués
alors première question les pierres
précieuses
ont-elles un produit directement comme
les autres les pierres précieuses sont
plus d'investissements comme les autres
elles comprennent des risques bien
entendu mais elle garde toujours une
forte demande actuelle sur le plan
mondial qui permet de maintenir les
marchés avaient levé juste avant la
deuxième marque olivier évoqué le fait
qu'on pouvait choisir des quatre
catcheurs 14 ordinale
est ce que fait un produit dans l'est
plus quand il a accepté la tour ou si on
parle de proue des investissements et
forêts le choisir des pierres précieuses
d'une certaine qualité
par exemple si j'étais dans le diamant
il ne faut pas choisir des diamants de
trop petite taille il faut choisir des
tiers de 3 à 5 carats parce qu'elles
sont plus rares dame nature à caen
été un peu plus peindre pour en produire
donc il faut plus axé là-dessus et on a
un investissement à moyen terme nous
intéressant tout ça sens oui oui enfin
sur votre région table d'investissement
où il faut chaud faut mettre un minimum
de deux budgets pour avoir une pierre
intéressant sur le moyen terme pour pour
vraiment rentabiliser son investissement
oui tout à fait et sait combien le
minimum minimum il faut en comment dire
en quoi il faut au minimum à kara il
faut choisir des couleurs et des puretés
de très bonne qualité à voir surtout
bien entendu comment s'appelle très bons
certificats l'enseignement c'est le ji
est il faut savoir que quand on achète
une pierre précieuse il faut toujours
toujours avoir le certificat qui est
parfait et qui est reconnue au niveau au
niveau mondial donc pour le diamant 6e j
ai pour les pierres de couleur c'est le
ssf ou le bugle inquiets suisse
lg bien sûr et américains et après en
valeur au minimum cinquante mille euros
si on parle vraiment de valeur
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on trouve que la violence
quelle est la carène préfet n'a pu
demander au rugby et le saphir de
cachemire de sons et des biens sur les
diamants de couleurs diamant au diamant
bleu qui sont des pierres très demandé
mais qui ont une très très grande valeur
je dirais saison des pierres qui sont
quand même très rare et attendait que la
population mondiale augmente donc cette
demande mathématiquement augmente aussi
surfer à chier quoi l'idée selon la côte
est et la britannique knight frank en
dix ans entre 2009 et 2019 le prix des
diamants a bondi de 13% et celui des
pierres précieuses coloré l2 sans doute
pourtant comment est ce qu'on fait
depuis quatre mois je pense que la
première chose c'est que en effet il ya
une ya de plus en plus de gens qui qui
peuvent accéder à ce genre
d'investissement et puis aussi parce
qu'il ya une défiance sur sur les actifs
autres et donc vous avez beaucoup de
gens qui comme sur l'or sont sortis de
ce sont des bancs arisée sont sortis de
leurs banques sont sorties de leurs
investissements je dirais classiques et
sont allés se réfugier sur du tangible
alors donc des pierres des de l'or de
l'argent des pièces etc
donc vous avez vous avez une une hausse
continuelle alors j'aime pas beaucoup
les indices je pense que philippe est
comme moi parce que les indices c1
c'est un groupement de petites pierres
grosses pierres ecsta donc que
évidemment c'est ça ne reflète pas
réellement la valeur de ces pierres dont
il parlait c'est à dire des pierres qui
sont exceptionnelles et qui l ont
généralement beaucoup plus monter que ça
m'est donc vous avez il faut pas ce
forcément se fier à ces à ces indices
qui sont un amalgame de pierre de
différentes tailles différentes de
différentes qualités
oui tout à fait mais faut aussi penser
une chose puis les gisements se
raréfient si vous prenez le saphir de
cachemire on en trouve pratiquement plus
c'est très très dur de les détruire de
cachemire actuellement
donc forcément ça peut remonter la
valeur et la demande continue à être
très soutenue en amérique
concrètement aujourd'hui à camplong
avait été dans les pires créatures alors
il ya plusieurs risques il faut il faut
il faut les prendre en compte si on fait
un départ très bien essayé il faut
absolument comme s'il est dit avoir un
très bon certificat le certificat
beaucoup de certificats actuellement il
y en a quelques-uns qui font autorité il
faut choisir ses certificats faut être
très bien
seillier bien entendu vous pas de
précipitation et puis les pierres il
faut vraiment les sélectionner un
maximum donc ma revanche
en temps de crise comme disait tout à
l'heure il est vrai le bas forcément le
monde s'est un petit peu arrêté pendant
pendant deux à trois mois
il est vrai que du coup on a eu beaucoup
moins de demandes d'achat et il y avait
quand même des pierres qui étaient en
stock mais actuellement on en décembre
ou en septembre
ça y est les comment dire les vêtements
de repart de nouveau
et voilà donc c'est un canton de crise
bas il faut un petit peu faire un peu le
feront attendre que ça se passe et puis
après ça remonte assez rapidement après
je pense que aussi c c'est un
investissement qui est tout de même
assez spécial c'est à dire vous
investissez pas dans une dans une pierre
précieuse comme même comme vous
investissez dans l'or c'est pas le même
genre d'investissement d'abord parce
qu'il ya une partie aussi
coup de coeur je pense dans le sait
exactement comme si vous comme quand
vous achetez un tableau vous avez une
partie coup de coeur et puis vous avez
aussi c'est des investissements qui ne
se font pas à la semaine ou à la minute
comme on al'habitude de d'avoir
maintenant en bourse avec même les
transactions à haute fréquence qui font
que le trading haute fréquence qui font
que vous ne gardez vos titres que
quelques nanosecondes là il faut savoir
que quand vous achetez une pierre c'est
pas pour les dix jours qui suivent
et c'est un investissement de long terme
comment avec leur écot à courre parler
d'eux on parle souvent de l'or comme
valeur vos furets et qu'on peut
d'ailleurs chose et pierre couture c'est
difficile de dire que c'est une valeur
refuge
elle est de par ce fait part à sa
réflexion est comment dire le coup qui
fait qu' elle augmente régulièrement
mais l'or comme et côté les côtés en
course lors aille à l'once d'or ya le
lingot et les pierres précieuses
il n'y a pas un coup au niveau mondial
sur le carat sauf pour le dire
bien entendu mais c'est pas c'est pas
tout à fait comme l'or c'est pas tous
ces gars comme une monnaie déjà leur
être considérée elle malgré tout comme
une monnaie donc c'est quand même
différent
en plus il ya il ya quelque chose qui
est que vient de dire philippe qui est
intéressant par rapport à l'or c'est que
vous n'avez pas de pierres précieuses
papier ça n'existe pas donc ce ne sont
que des transactions physiques que vous
allez avoir donc vous ne pouvez pas
comme sur l'or vendre pour un milliard
de dollars dont 11 d'or sans en avoir le
moindre la moindre gramme donc ce que
vous pouvez faire aujourd'hui en bourse
donc vous pouvez manipuler le cours vous
savez que sur l'or vous avez une once
d'or physique pour 311 d'or papier donc
vous avez un marché du papier qui ne
correspond à rien et qui est énorme 300
fois supérieur au marché physique ça
vous ne le retrouvais pas dans les
pierres précieuses donc vous les pierres
précieuses c'est une transaction
physique et donc vous ne pouvez pas en
vendre si vous n'en avez pas et ça
change tout ça change tout sur le court
aussi de deux sur la valeur c'est à dire
que vous avez une valeur qui aura
beaucoup moins de volatilité que l'or
qui peut se faire manipuler par des
banques qui ont envie à un moment de
jouer dessus donc là
sur sur le diamant il ya eu quelques
tentatives de titrisation du diamant
mais qui sont général arrêté assez assez
rapidement et ce ne sont que des
transactions physiques donc c'est très
différent tout de même d'un
investissement sûr sur l'or ou sur
l'argent merci à l'auteur remarque une
courte passe bien dans 20 ans
bienvenue dans ces cas si vous nous
rejoignez au programme aujourd'hui à
l'écart précieuse avec elle sur le crawl
un négociant en pierres précieuses et
joaillerie monsieur alain juste avant la
coupure pub olivier évoqué le fait
qu'ils aient beaucoup moins de
volatilité sur le marché des pierres
précieuses qu'être d'accord avec ça oui
parce que j'ai tourné que c'est une
matière physique qu'on possède premier
entre les marches
donc ça limite la volubilité parce que
forcément elle se traite par papier on
part par là pour sa part qu'une
plateforme de transactions possibles
est ce que par exemple elle a l'air
d'une pierre peuvent perdre du jour au
lendemain la valeur du tiers j'irai pas
peut perdre entrant en crise
elle peut se mettre en repos kir en
attente en quelque sorte
bien sûr si on attend en temps de crise
il ya moins de demande pas forcément ça
va intéresser des gens qui veulent faire
des très bonne opération qu'ils savent
que une fois la crise passée qui sait ce
qu'est partie la demande va repartir
mais on n'a jamais vu deux tiers perdent
vraiment si le certificat est vraiment
vraiment de qualité et d'une grande
maison
non la pierre ne part pas de valeur elle
ne risque pas prendre ça c'est vrai mais
nous perdra pas tolérés
outre le fait que la pierre précieuse
pendant accessible à tous est ce que
cette rumeur en avait huit mois qu'on
peut considérer comme ça qu'ils en terme
de logistique est plus facile à attaquer
car un carlin go par exemple c'est non
seulement le stockage est beaucoup plus
facile puisque vous pouvez avoir dans
dans un
à une pierre qui fait la taille d'un
ongle vous pouvez avoir une pierre qui
vaut cinq cent mille 1 million ou plus
donc évidemment que c'est plus facile
pour le stockage
c'est aussi plus facile pour en termes
de transport parce que si vous voulez
faire cinq cent mille euros je vous
rappelle quand même que ça représente 10
kilos d'or et que dix kilos d'or
vous le transporter pas comme ça ça
déforme un peu les poches donc et puis
ça ça le mauvais goût en plus de ne pas
passer sous les sous les portiques de
douane donc non évidemment que c'est
beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup plus facile
alors dire que c'est plus accessible non
c'est pas nous accessible par dont un
problème vous avez un problème de
sécurité mais dès que vous avez un actif
de toute façon réelle que ce soit un
tableau qui a de la valeur que ce soit
des lingots d'or que ce soit
des pierres vous avez un problème de
sécurité oui c'est pas une bonne idée
d'aller l'intérêt au fond du jardin
c'est clair mais vous avez la
possibilité tout de même de mettre ça
dans un coffre est de mettre ça à l'abri
et beaucoup plus facilement avec une
pierre parce que c'est beaucoup plus
petit donc c'est plus facile imposable
oui oui après cette fille impose ça fait
ça puisque à lille en france et les
pierres précieuses au rang dans l'est
est sèche
bien entendu mais comme l'exigent sf
n'existe plus pour moi je suis je suis
en suisse mais eux c'est le sénégal
depuis sa rentrée dans le sfb au bout du
sida certain temps il n'y a pas là il
n'y a pas de plus value sur leur grande
des pierres c'est quand même davantage
donc une opposition qui est quand même
beaucoup plus souple que que d'autres
bien le bien immobilier il y aura un
public surtout quand même beaucoup plus
forte la plus value est comme moins
importante sur le cas précis je dirais
que pour l'instant il n'y a plus de sf
malheureusement il est quand même assez
probable qu'ils reviennent au galop
parce que je rappelle que la france est
endettée et que la dette c'est de
l'impôt donc vous allez bientôt avoir un
isf très probablement qui va ressortir
sous une forme ou sous une autre alors
maintenant est ce qu'il y aura les
pierres précieuses dedans je n'en sais
rien je ne suis pas dans les petits
papiers de monsieur macro et donc ni de
ce nid de ceux de bruno le maire est
donc je ne peux pas vous le dire mais
c'est pas impossible qu'à un moment
cherchant de l'argent partout
il ré impose ce genre d'actifs à
monsieur aulas est que les pierres
précieuses peuvent poser les problèmes
de traçabilité par exemple qu'il y avait
d extraction sauvage c'est ce qu'on leur
demandait ce que vous être confronté à
toulon des problèmes non on n'est pas
confronté à ce genre de problème étant
donné que l les pierres précieuses en
l'occurrence pour ma part que je vends
sont toutes avec certificat donc ces
certificats sont des laboratoires
reconnus
donc à partir du moment où le
laboratoire certifie une pierre il sait
sa provenance
donc il a fait en amont la conduire la
traçabilité en quelque sorte
donc on n'a pas de problème si on a une
pierre avec certificat pour la
traçabilité par exemple france au
diamant en diamant de 200 non c'est pas
possible avec un certificat c'est pas
possible étant donné qu'elle passe par
des bureaux et par service de recherche
de traçabilité avant d'être certifié
bien à moi monsieur voir le monde à
travers ses écrits sans précédent et que
le marché avec l'ère chrétien et qu'il a
été touché à au même titre que d'autres
marchés le marché des pierres précieuses
- là évidemment s'arrêter un petit peu
plus ou moins de travailler pendant deux
mois parce qu'on pouvait plus voyager il
y avait eu non plus de salon sur le plan
mondial même certaines ventes aux
enchères n'avait pas lieu
donc c'est vrai que le marché s'est un
petit peu arrêté mais on voit que par
exemple quotidien blick et tout à
l'heure sur les diamants les grandes
firmes des 36e comment dire firme
minière au pour le diamant retiennent la
marchandise en amont pour maintenir les
prix les prix assez élevé et dès que le
marché redémarre automatiquement c'est
vrai que l'on voit de nouveau les
pierres pire apparaissent sur le marché
donc mais le marché n'a pas perdu en
temps qu'elle il s'est mis au repos
s'est mis un petit peu repos certaines
personnes moi j'ai eu quelques j'ai eu
des demandes bien sûr pendant la crise
des personnes comme on dit un monsieur
de rothschild disais toujours fait
acheter au son du canon faut pas hésiter
donc certaines personnes m'ont dit
écoutez moi je souhaite toujours
investir en ce moment il ya toujours
bien
du autant de autant de cash dans le
monde et des gens avertis souhaite
diversifier leur patrimoine au liban
années vous aviez choisi un
investissement plutôt or ont plutôt
pierre chrétien
les deux que l'aude il n'y a pas de il
faut pas être exclusif
justement il faut diversifier donc oui
alors oui à l'argent métal
oui aux pierres et
et oui aussi parce qu'on en a pas parlé
mais les bijoux anciens dont philips
s'est fait aussi une spécialité les
bijoux anciens sont des choses
intéressantes
d'abord parce que je crois qu'il n'était
pas fiscalisés quand c'était des bijoux
qui était qui avait plus de plus de 40
ans ou 50 ans j'ai plus exactement la
date il ne rentrait pas dans les sf et
en plus vous avez certaines grandes
maisons
de joaillerie qui rachète les bijoux
anciens qui sont des icônes de leur
magasin de lors de leur production et
donc vous avez un marché qui est
intéressant avec des des prix qui
forment un investissement intéressant je
crois que je me trompe pas fini c'est
assez impressionnant
les bijoux anciens nous sommes
confrontés par les grandes maisons
cartier van cleef et d'autres qui
souhaite racheter leurs propres bijoux
est d'ailleurs qualifiée quartier a créé
un département quartier d'un tri moines
h où il garde ses bijoux ou alors ils
remettent tout simplement en vente alors
parfois ils peuvent les transformer une
broche qui est un petit peu moins à la
mode il ya la transforme en collier et
de par ce fait ils remettent à la vente
et ses impôts terrasse ça a énormément
de valeur
oui tout à fait c'est un marché qui a
vraiment vraiment explosé à m'excuser et
ça c'est bon merci beaucoup à tous les
problèmes
pour cette analyse n'a osé philippe
rolland je rappelle que revêtent
négociant en pierres précieuses et joies
et les oliviers nous on continue avec
les questions cash et comme à chaque
sont des missions olivier delamarche
répond à vos questions des questions que
vous pouvez déposer sur les réseaux
sociaux en commentaires des vidéos parmi
eux les questions sélectionnées cette
semaine celle de produits qu'avez vous
pensé de la visite des manuels maquereau
ou vivant est raisonnable d'intervenir
dans un pays étranger alors même que la
france est plongée dans l'une des plus
grandes crises de son histoire
et bien c'est justement parce que la
france est plongée en crise que monsieur
macron
va à l'étranger si seulement il pouvait
le garder et en faire leur président ça
nous débarrasserait mais non je trouve
que c'est encore une fois c'est assez
ridicule de voir là des gens qui sont
incapables de régler nos problèmes et
qu'ils vont se permettre de donner des
leçons à des pays étrangers qui sont
dans des dans une situation plus que
difficile mais au moins peut être
espérons qu'il se renseigne sur ce que
deviendra la france s'il continue comme
ça
en 2030 puisque nous sommes en plein à
tout cas à mon avis en pleine
libanisation donc j'ai une deuxième
réflexion à propos de la visite de
monsieur macron c'est le le la sortie
qu'il a fait
par rapport à ce qu'avait écrit monsieur
malbrunot il faut qu'ils avaient écrit
qu'il avait rencontré le hezbollah
ce qui était vrai et donc il ne l'a pas
nié un simplement visiblement quand on
dit la vérité et quand on dit un certain
nombre de choses qui ne plaisent pas à
monsieur macron monsieur macron ses
nerfs il faudrait quand même lui
expliquer que dans une démocratie 1
on a le droit et on a le devoir même de
savoir ce que magouilles nos élites donc
je trouve sa sortie totalement
ahurissante et il faudrait que l'on
revienne à des choses un petit peu plus
normal alors je sais que le masque
aujourd'hui nous protège contre le virus
j'aimerais bien aussi qui ne sert pas à
bâillonner les gens c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant pour voir ou
revoir nos précédents numéros rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
rennais le mot de la fin
écoutez investissez dans les pierres non
seulement ça vous fera gagner de
l'argent et en plus ça fera plaisir à
vos femmes